Jeffree Star was talking about gender
binary and he came out he was saying
like the vedem stuff just doesn't make
sense and he's also spoken out against
gender transitions for children saying
they're not ready for that that sort of
thing that's why I made a video and I
said obviously this YouTuber has a lot
of controversy but this is something
that we can commend at least so my
audience can commend he's saying protect
children there we go and people were
like no but he said all those like other
stuff and I don't like him I'm not like
raw Raj every Star I love all your
videos but I'm like that was a good
thing you're male or you're female how
are you with they what the does
that mean as stupid as what it is yeah
but you need someone like me that looks
like me to say it